let's talk about your hair my hair we're
not washing her hair for a week I'm
crying why are we doing this
I basically don't shampoo my hair
most times already so I think I'm good
on this challenge apparently you don't
wash your hair some people say that
their hair is like better moisturize or
you know it looks shinier maybe because
sometimes shampoos can be sort of harsh
and they can dry out your hair do you
have any like social obligations that
you're concerned about
yeah I have some social obligations here
I mean one thing a normal human that's
out - I just pick up again I'm afraid my
hair's gonna get real greasy and gross I
think I'm gonna be looking pretty ugly
I'm like tomorrow Friday Saturday like
gonna be interesting stay tuned no
shampooing I think my hair looks crazy
this is day three of not washing my hair
and yeah there it is it just feels bad
like when I laid a pillow that's the
beach it's a beautiful day after this my
hair is just gonna be disgusting I
honestly don't know if I'm gonna make it
it looks real flat in the back I think
people could see that maybe I've got a
real flat head and I look like a cup and
candle I imagine doesn't smell that
great you they're like oh yeah it don't
smell good
oh that is pungent look how greasy a
hook like it looks wet it's not as
greasy as I thought it would be all I
wanted to do is use some dry shampoo why
are you doing this week
this was really really hard my hair
doesn't smell as much as I thought it
would but it's it's not pleasant smells
like the first couple days of not
washing my hair I actually kind of like
but as the week went on it was just
chaos
I just feel disgusting my hair looks
like it's wet even though it's not every
morning I woke up with a weird hairstyle
I think maybe if I'd done it for longer
than a week my body would have figured
out what was going on and tried to
naturally compensate or something but
after a week it's just a trash a big
pile of trash up here so you know I
don't recommend it
you